so hereditary is one of those movies
that blew me away when I first watched
it back in 2018. by far it's my favorite
Aries to film and though I've already
done a big breakdown on it I thought I'd
revisit the movie to celebrate the
release of Bowers afraid you see back
when I made that first video in 2020 I
was still learning the ropes and since
then we bought new equipment hired
editors and just tried to up our game in
terms of the level that we pick movies
apart I've never been happy with that
video because of how much I missed in
the initial watch through and thus I've
decided to return once more to this
classic to an Earth all the hidden
things in it throughout this video we'll
be going through every creepy little
detail it's ending and also why I love
the movie so much this High concept
horror was released during a time that
there was a big Revival in the genre and
alongside it we had movies like The
Witch the double Rich the Apostle the
ritual and a lot more they really broke
the mold and moved away from the
stereotypical cheap jump scare tactic
that so many movies relied on instead
the film's laced with this feeling of
dread that slowly Bells throughout it
and this is seen right from the off we
begin with an obituary for Ellen Lee and
throughout the film we learn more and
more about her and not only was she the
grandmother and mother to the family
that we focus on but she was also the
queen of the cult of payment when doing
my research I found that payments one of
the eight Kings of hell and he has the
ability to create hallucinations
reanimate the dead and all sodogram
flight these are all things that happen
in the movie and you can kind of piece
what's going on with them before we join
them the morning well in his funeral now
turns out that Ellen actually offered a
person Charles so that he could be a
vessel for payment and we see his name
in this opening obituary we later
learned that Charles took his own life
and the note that he left accused her of
trying to put people inside of him this
was diagnosed as schizophrenia but in
hindsight we know that he was actually
telling the truth now because of his
death Alan couldn't offer up a vessel
but this didn't stop her from carrying
out her plans Ellen also had order named
Annie and she patiently waited until she
had a son named Peter however Annie and
Ellen weren't really on speaking terms
at the time and thus the evil grandma
wasn't able to sink her claws in however
they did repair the relationship years
later and Annie had a daughter named
Charlie named after her deceased brother
Ellen apparently said that she wanted a
boy and at one point we even see a
customized map with the name Charles on
it instead of Charlie they were clearly
hoping that Annie would have another son
but they may do and went ahead with
putting the spirit of payment into
Charlie however payment desperately
desired a male body and thus he didn't
grant them the riches that they'd been
promised now the entire story of
hereditary centers around transferring
payments spurred into Peter but in order
to do this they have to carry out
certain rituals there's a ton of
foreshadowing and things that don't pay
off until much later and we actually
begin where we end with us getting a
strong focus on the Treehouse this pulls
out to Annie's Studio which is where we
see several of her Miniatures before we
then move into a recreation of Peter's
Room the film does a Festival job in
giving this idea that summing's
constantly watching the family and this
is demonstrated perfectly in the opening
as we get further into the model it then
transitions into Peter's real room and
this was done for a symbolic reason now
personally I I've always taken this to
show that the characters are like
puppets that don't really have any
control over what's going on this is
given a little not too later on in the
film many happens during one of the many
classroom scenes we hear the story of
Heracles and learn the analysis given is
that the character doesn't really have
any control over their fate so he thinks
he has control
but let's all remember Sophocles wrote
The Oracle so that it was unconditional
meaning Heracles never had any choice
right this is almost like a Greek
tragedy in which the audience would
watch the events play out where the
characters unaware that an audience was
there the way the Miniatures transform
into the location also gives this idea
that this is somewhat of a stage and if
we're getting better then we're very
much watching an actor on set construct
it much like these Miniatures a
classroom analysis also surmises there
were signs all around the characters
that they refuse to acknowledge much
like the people that we meet in the film
because he literally refuses to look at
all the signs that are being literally
handed to him the entire play and he
creates these Miniatures in order to
comprehend and deal with certain
situations but they could also signify
that the cult have constructed their
entire world dolls appear throughout the
film namely in Jones apartment and with
Charlie he also makes her own using the
heads of dead animals and they actually
did a bit of viral marketing for the
movie with the dolls being available on
Etsy under the name crafts by Charlie
Jean if you if you want to buy me
something for Christmas I'll set up a PO
Box mate and you can send that out looks
great now the headings are also Rife in
the movie too and we see from the
picture of payment that he rides around
with three by his side these three are
needed for the ritual to be carried out
and in the movie this is represented by
Ellen's beheading Charlie's and lastly
Annie's early on in Peter's Room we get
a little nod towards this and we can see
Three Hats hanging up on his wall now
before you go at me for reaching I think
that the colors of these actually show
that these have some significance and
he's seen film wearing a denim shirt
with white under it and this is the same
as the Hat on the left Charlie where's
that giant orange hoodie much like the
middle one and lastly Ellen wears cream
like the one on the right now after
Peter is woken up his dad Steve goes out
of the tree house which is where we're
introduced to Charlie even though it's
freezing she still ends up sleeping here
and this is where payment returns to in
order to complete his rebirth it
perfectly recontextualizes this
happening scene and shows her payment
felt at home here which is why he
returns come the films close and the
funeral itself is actually filled with
cult members and any even remarks that
it's surprising to see so many new
people there it's heartening to see so
many
strange new faces here today she also
mentions about how her mother was a well
well I'll let Annie say it my mother was
a very secretive
and private woman
she had private rituals private friends
private anxieties these private rituals
and private friends were all payment
related and they had to keep things
secret because of what they were
actually up to yeah we also see Annie's
necklace which is exactly the same as
the one her mother wears in the casket
when we get a close-up shot of it we can
actually see the shapes in the center
represent the three heads and this is
symbol itself is in our tomb it appears
throughout the film and later shows up
on the post where Charlie's decapitated
at before appearing in the Attic the two
shows up on the mat in Joan's house and
on the cover of the bug detailing
payments history now Charlie spots this
and when she looks up she sees a man
creepily smiling at her this is the same
guy who shows up naked later on in the
house and we catch him standing in the
doorway after Peter discovers his dad's
corpse anyway Charlie clicks her tongue
at the funeral like and this is like a
used to denote that the demon has moved
from her into her brother they also do
some brilliant shorthand as we see
Charlie jumping away on a chocolate bar
which he uses his comfort food in
situations where she feels awkward my
dad asks if it has nuts in it and this
sets up both the reaction later on and
while she feels like she has to go for
the cake at the party when she's left on
her own and the family returned home and
there's a nice bit of sound Direction
where we can actually hear people moving
about the house before the family enter
I'll boost the volume in case you missed
that and listen again closely
now I pointed that out in our initial
breakdown but one thing I noticed on top
of this is that Steven says that Charlie
takes her shoes off everybody Charlie
shoes off later on when Charlie's been
walking outside in her socks and he also
tells her to take them off before she
takes her own shoes off we're going to
this hey it starts off you're going to
this party with your brother
parents tend to do this when they're mad
at the kids are constantly leaving
Footprints about the house but in
hindsight we know who this is later on
in the movie when Peter comes in we can
see there's muddy Footprints all over
the floor and it's likely that this
isn't from the family instead I think
these were left behind by the cult and
Steve was angry there with footprints in
the house all the time because they were
constantly coming in and out later on we
learned they moved Ellen's body to the
attic and that a triangle had also been
drawn on the floor both of which
probably happened when people were
leaving these mocks anyway after Steve
says good night to Peter we cut to
Charlie's room and then see all her
dolls later on we get a payment statue
in the tree house and this actually
somewhat resembles the figures that we
get here The Stance is the same with the
long legs and on the back shelf we can
see one with a Golden Crown now Charlie
and Peter both have opposite reactions
to their Grandma dying with a ladder
being lackadaisical to it whilst Charlie
is clearly torn up and he says you know
you were her favorite she wouldn't let
me feed you because she needed to feed
you and we actually see a picture
roughly the 24 minute Mark and here we
can catch her feeding Charlie with a
bottle be look closely there's actually
a very important detail here and this
highlights what the Wicked Woman was up
to the top of the bottle has some weird
green things floating around in it and
this is the same as what Annie pulls out
the tea that Joan gives a later on when
going through her mother's possessions
towards the end of the movie Annie
briefly touches a green bottle now we
can see that this says didn't he of
Crete a huge shout outs to and I can't
believe this username sold my soul to
paymen who pointed out on Reddit that
this is actually a magical herb did any
of credence believed to be something
that can make someone astral project and
leave their body so that others can then
enter it Alan was feeding this to
Charlie at a young age and joaned it to
Annie so that she could be taken over
too you also know from the diorama that
she wanted to breastfeed the girl as
well and he's had such a creepy extra
layer to the movie about control and
possession possession can have a double
meaning in this case with Ellen using
her children as objects rather than
seeing them as actual people and he says
that Charlie never cried when she was
born and throughout her childhood we
know this is because of what's really
going on now at this point she looks up
and sees the words to Tony written on
the wall this is where the polls from
necromancy and little phrases like this
appear throughout the movie lift ouch in
pandemonium has scribbled in the house
too with the former of these meaning
open the latter means chaos and the
words all have meanings that are rooted
in possession now something sinister is
definitely going on here and Annie
discovers a book about notes on
spiritualism with a letter from her
mother his promises rewards and payments
state that his followers would be
showered with riches now after she turns
out the lights we can make out Ellen's
ghosts standing in the dark it's one of
the most unnerving parts of the movie
and it's so creepy seeing her standing
there in the darkness and the next day
we see Charlie at school trying to stick
the head of a toy back into its body but
she's unable to do this at this point a
bird flies into the classroom window and
she ends up cutting this off for the
figure this is when we catch one of the
cult members watching her and she
actually also appears in the Attic later
on now on the opposite side of the
school we see Peter and a lesson and at
this point we also meet the girl Bridget
she's played off as the typical love
interest that doesn't really go anywhere
but there's actually an extreme
possibility that she's part of the cult
too now in order to talk about this we
have to go on at least I'm gonna blow
your mind gonna blow your mind with
period times
so we know that at the very least that
one of Peter's Pals was in The Cult of
payment under the bleachers we catch him
in his pile smoking and on the left we
can see someone who has a tied up
ponytail come the end of the film we see
in the treehouse that there is someone
kneeling down to payment and this guy
has the exact same haircut that his
friend does here I did talk about this
in our last breakdown but I felt I
needed to bring this back up before we
get into Bridget after Peter gives a
dumb answer in class she ends up turning
around in her seat and staring directly
at him which is a bit out of place like
no no girls ever stared at me like that
before you know you know what I mean you
you can relate you're a loser as well
either way though she plays a key role
in the film and she's the person who
takes Peter away at the party when he's
supposed to be looking after Charlie
this allows her to eat the cake which
then leads into her beheading as Peter
drives away and tries to get back home
now we do see her Facebook profile later
on and if we look at the wall of photos
we can see one in the top right that has
a lot of significance in here we see
here with a raised arm and a hand bent
forward which is summing at all certain
notes payment this is what we see the
statue in the tree house doing and it
also happens to Peter in the classroom
when The Possession takes hold if we
look at the name on the tab along the
top we can also see that his surname is
mopay huge shout outs to the many face
girl on Reddit but noticing this and it
has its own meaning that ties in with
the film this isn't exactly a common
name like I I don't know anyone multi
and I know at least 10 people and if we
look at the words Origins it actually
means siren in case you don't know a
siren was a creature that was thought to
lure Sailors to their deaths and Bridget
could be seen as a figure that draws
Peter in anyway
was it right what's it wrong I'll leave
it up to you just comment please don't
[__] comment please I'm begging
not after any discovers the triangle in
her mother's room Steve learns Allen's
body has been stolen from the cemetery
he keeps his quiet from his wife to not
cause any more grief and she lies
herself and says that she's going to see
a movie instead she's attending a group
counseling session and in hindsight if
we pay attention to Joan on the right
here we can see she's completely fixated
on her now we've set aside some time for
any newcomers that might like to speak
so when the counselor asks if anyone
would like to speak she immediately
looks over to her almost willing her to
talk and she stays staring at her until
she decides to speak she brings up how
her mother had did AKA dissociative
identity disorder this involves someone
having multiple distinct personalities
who could even come from her trying to
offer herself up to payment later on
John introduces herself to Annie and she
talks about how she lost her son and
also her grandson it was only through
doing this watch through that I thought
it might be connected to payment and
potentially she could have tried to
force them to become vessels as well now
later on Joan performs the Seance with
Annie and she does this through what she
says is her grandson's favorite
chalkboard however we know that was a
[__] lie as when Annie bumps into her
in the car park we can see what she's
been buying as the characters walk past
her car if you pause it on the open
trunk you can see that she's bought a
chalkboard set including the one she
later uses the cult are clearly trying
to plant the idea into Annie's Hair that
she needs to carry out his seons and
this is also indicated when we see
letters piling through the letterbox a
separate flyer advertising as Seance is
posted through over the top of these so
that any will see this first before
anything else she doesn't end up
pretending though unless Jones steps in
and makes things up with the chalkboard
Ariana said that he used this to show
the cult were constantly planning
different ways to get the family and had
Charlie's head not gone out the window
with the deer then something else would
have been used now I also think this
grief scene has a lot going on beneath
the surface and hearing any recount
stories of her family's mental illness
could play into the title itself the
name hereditary has a lot going on with
it and it can mean things passed on
genetically through her family and he
has almost set up her own family in a
similar structure to what she had as a
child without being a father mother son
and a daughter on a first watch before
the reveal of the supernatural elements
uh I was sure this film would be about
mental illness and how traits are passed
on Down the Line This is what it seemed
like when she was rattling off the
issues about her family and it's
possible that this is actually the case
the now playing podcast went into when
payment really came to the Forefront of
myths and legends and this happened
during the 15th century they dug up a
Dutch figurehead who had pushed him
forth who also had his own roots in the
study of mental health he was the person
who put for the idea that women accused
of being witches could actually be
dealing with mental health issues and
ariaster actually brought in elements of
this into the movie it was only on this
viewing that I even considered the
entire plot of the film may just be the
imaginings of someone having a psychotic
breakdown the family history is
definitely there to support that now one
thing that you only learn in the
supplemental material is that Steve's a
therapist and that Annie was his patient
her brother too went to his episode at
the same age that Steve is now and upon
doing my research I encoded something
else to support that it's all mental
when looking up symptoms of
schizophrenia it's said that people who
suffer from it often see lights and
people that aren't actually there this
could potentially be the lights in the
cult and though I do take things
literally in the movie I love that
there's another way that you can look at
all of the elements either way the title
hereditary is echoed in the credits in
which we see one letter from each name
dropping down into the next one this
signifies the passing down of genetics
much like how the possession of payment
is passed down the family too anyway
back in Peter's Room we see him blowing
smoke out the window and if you pay
close attention to the left side of the
screen you can catch someone watching
him due to the breath coming out their
mouth in Charlie's room we see payments
light and this is used throughout the
film to highlight certain things this is
a higher power stepping through the
influence events and it leads Charlie
outside which is where she Witnesses a
ritual Peter spots it in the classroom
and it also appears to Annie while she's
working on a miniature the light appears
at the blinds and then Annie seemingly
knocks our paint pot which then draws
attention to Jones number let's watch
that again in slo-mo though and pay
close attention to that blue bottle if
you zoom in and look closely you'll see
that Annie never actually touched the
paint part and that this fellow above
its own accord it was purposely pushed
to show Jon's number and the light tends
to guide people but in the case of Peter
it does have a hold over him you might
notice that a beam of light shines down
from the rafters directly onto Peta and
then he starts to suffocate like his
sister's not allergy the classroom scene
is the classroom scene and he ends up
smashing his head like it's the like
button on this video anyway at the party
he watches Bridget takes Peter upstairs
and catch people watching a video on a
laptop if you look closely this is
actually showing a guillotine tying back
to one of the key motifs in the film
it's not long until Peter heads off and
Charlie heads off too and all the
theories I had about her being one of
the big characters they go out the
window
and this is when the film took a massive
left turn for me and I remember in the
cinema that so many people had a
different reaction to it there were some
people that laughed others that gasped
and yeah I just remember this moment
hitting harder then Charlie hit that
post now Peter returns home in shock and
Annie discovers her daughter's body in
the morning which sends her into
agonizing grief one thing that you
wouldn't know unless you read the script
is that annealing on the ground like
this is supposed to foreshadow the end
of the movie and how the cult will bow
before payment Charlie is buried and we
see her father going through her notepad
which is when he comes across a sketch
of a bird this has been beheaded and it
wears a crown and also has a beak that
looks like scissors tying back to her
cutting it off and he spends the night
in the tree house with the hitters on to
keep it warm and she truly feels lost
without her daughter she was far closer
to her than she was to her son and as
soon as he shows up at the house she
ends up driving out after being invited
out by Joan we see the first clue that
she was Ellen's friend and this comes
from the Welcome outside her house
Welcome Matt
oh it's kind of cute huh my mother used
to embroidery once just like that and he
talks about the time she almost set
herself on fire and later she carries
this out was a psychotic break and again
it ties in this idea of mental health
got back to the house and we get a
better look at the miniature in which
there's a house built on top of a house
to me this is hereditary in itself and
it shows how the past is built upon the
past it goes beyond taking blood and
genetics from people it's things about
them like their mannerisms that also get
carried across and the idea of what a
family should be which is what this
represents we get tension at the dinner
table and the family drama ramps up as
the Cults start to close in now
interestingly Annie at this point says
to Peter something about how he always
has that stupid face on his face and all
I get back is that [__] face on your
face we don't really know what this
means because Peter always seems pretty
low-key and normal however if we look at
some of the other scenes in the film
that there is something could hint at
what this means in one of the classroom
scenes Peter sees an evil reflection of
himself then we can catch this smiling
back at him it's possible that this face
is what Annie saw too and this is why
she thinks he's walking around with that
stupid face on his face now Annie is
coerced into doing a seance and that
night she sees ants crawling on her
pillow and then around the room and of
course will follow a queen and with him
gravitating towards her it could show
that she's now being selected as the
person to give up their son she follows
these ants through lapida's room and
they crawl over his head just like how
they crawled over Charlie's at his point
she Envision setting herself and Peter
on fire which is when she's awakened and
realizes it's a dream when discussing
this ariaster said that and he's saying
she wasn't trying to kill him she was
trying to save him has its own meaning
to it and he actually had it within a
subconscious that she had to save Peter
from his fate but it's such a horrible
thing to carry out that she's in denial
she has to do it this is why she acts it
out in dreams but upon waking up she
buries it because she can't face up to
it she carries out a seance that seems
to bring Charlie into her and this
explains how she becomes possessed later
on at this point there's no going back
and the Seance being carried out is the
beginning of the end for the family
occur to the Knight and Peter awakens to
see what looks like Charlie's standing
over him in the corner of the room
someone tries to pull his head off and
though we never get confirmed who this
is I I think it's clearly Annie she made
the miniature before showing Peter with
a missing head and this could be a case
of her sleepwalking again now this could
also explain what happens with the book
in the next scene too and he goes to
burn it and this sets her on fire
however if we look at this from a
different angle it could actually be her
burning herself which we know is
something she's done before are we Cody
Jones and inside her house see a table
mapped out with various items on it
there's a triangle with Peter's face in
the middle and this looks similar to the
triangle on the floor that was
discovered in Ellen's room there's also
lots of Charlie's dolls and some dead
animal heads now this foreshadows the
ending and the three dolls we see
kneeling down represent the figures we
see kneeling to payment the three animal
heads show the three beheadings and they
originally would have been on the three
dolls we see kneeling they're all
looking to the payment doll which has a
bird's head and crown and this is of
course similar to Charlie's drawing
realizing the truth and he runs down the
hall and we get a lingering shot on her
neighbor's door showing the number 202
now I sold my soul to payment not me on
on the guy on Reddit they had a great
theory on what this could be and
depending on whether Jones home is 201
or 200 and may be tied in with payments
Legend payman was said to be one of
Lucifer's most loyal servants and in
hell he ruled over 200 angels and that
could be the case if the apartment's 200
and if it's Tier 1 it's my time with the
fact that payments followers on Earth
will call the 230 this Legion might be a
bloody reach you know but we do hang on
the 202 for a couple of seconds so just
reading into it anyway after Joan shouts
get out to Peter from across the street
and he discovers the mat in photo of
jion along with her mother going as back
Peter sees a light in the hallway in his
Steve writes an email about his consent
surrounding Annie he gets an email
showing what happened to Ellen's grave a
corpse is discovered in the attic and
though we probably can't show the
missing head he can see payment symbols
stitched into her dress Steve ends up
picking Peter up from school and he's
following a similar sort of story to
what Annie's own father did the
possession of mental stuff is clearly
passed on down through the mother's side
and much like her dad he finds himself
in this unwinnable situation weirdly
Peter and Stevia that the pair of played
father and son before and they did joke
about how they should do this every 10
years guys don't look anything alike
though so [__] knows why they keep
getting cast like that but moving on now
as he burns Annie stands there gasping
and you can see a light wash she over
here which is payment taking control now
from here we get an outside shot of the
house and watch as we go from day to
night this happens relatively quickly
and it doesn't seem like anything is
wrong however if we pause the frame on
the nighttime shot you can actually see
people standing out in the forest it
goes by so fast that you might miss it
but it's probably my favorite detail in
the entire film now we see as Steve
wakes up and looks about his room which
also has a really creepy detail in it
that you might miss if you boost the
brightness you can actually see Annie
standing in the top corner and when I
first noticed this I might have needed a
change of boxes yikes now she later
follows him downstairs and can be seen
standing above him as Peter discovers
his father at this point the Chase
Begins with Peter shutting himself in
the attic and Annie manages to make it
in even though he loxes and the only way
this is possible is if the cult members
unlock it from the inside and we know
that they are up in the attic Peter does
what we'd all do in this situation I
think and man just makes a run for it
right out the window definitely would
risk the broken bones over whatever the
[__] this is but in his we can state it
allows payment to take over it was said
that the body was needed to be weakened
and this happening means that he can
finally take control we see the light
touch his body and finally payments able
to possess the male that he's been so
Desperately Seeking now in our original
breakdown we said the shadow you see
floating out the garden is Peter's Soul
however this is wrong and this is
actually Annie's corpse which has just
been beheaded you hear the third of her
body dropping down after the chicken
wire makes its way through and from this
point she then flies into the tree house
as payment walks along we also see the
body of their dog showing that the cult
killed it so I couldn't alert the family
up in the tree house we hear what's
almost triumphant music you can get the
sounds of bells and trumpets in the
Legends it said that payments arrival
will be accompanied by these instruments
hence why they're used in the score here
Charlie's head is used on the Statue and
we can also see payment symbol right on
the chest the is a bird cage beside it
too calling back to the ones that have
appeared throughout the film and Joni
calls payment Charlie as she explains
exactly what's happening aryasta said
that his intention with this line was to
show that was never really a Charlie and
that in her body was the demon all along
this is what the click means and we
close out with a wide shot of the attic
film The once more like Miniatures it
appears like a stage and this continues
the Thematic idea it's all part of some
Greek tragedy that none of the
characters could escape from this has
its ties back to Classic films as well
and Aries to set its meant to mirror the
shot in the movie The Night of the
hunter placing them side by side you can
see how much it lines up and in the end
that closes out the movie really hope
you enjoyed watching us go back through
it and hopefully I pointed out some
stuff that you've missed in the film
we'll be back with another classic movie
breakdown really soon so if you enjoyed
this one then make sure you subscribe if
you want to get access to these videos
early then also consider joining our
membership program where we post video
like this as soon as they're made if you
want to melts to watch then the power of
Christ compels you to check out our
Brighton of The Exorcist which will be
linked on screen right now love
revisiting that film and I hope you do
too by the way I've been Paul I'll see
you next time you take care yourself and
enjoy the rest of the week peace